el 5 de noviembre momento de hablar de
economía quien france24 y por ello
recibo con mucho gusto a daniela
hablando con ramírez la especialista
económica danielle hablemos pues
inminente no de este proceso
postelectoral que vive eeuu y es que en
este país no sólo hay incertidumbre
electoral también hay incertidumbre
económica
alan muy buenas noches pues el país ha
estado paralizado en los últimos tres
días pero los que sí han estado muy
activos son los miembros del comité de
la reserva federal tras una reunión de
dos días el banco central dejó
inalteradas las tasas de interés en un
nivel que ya es históricamente bajo
así estimula el consumo y a su vez la
economía la fed también insistió en que
no basta con ayudas monetarias sino que
se necesita un empujón fiscal en plata
blanca se refiere a un paquete de
estímulos económicos aunque deja claro
que quieres que sea el congreso el que
lo decida escuchemos
es el apoyo proporcionado fue
absolutamente esencial para respaldar la
recuperación que hemos visto hasta ahora
que en general ha superado las
expectativas
y creo que es probable que se necesite
más apoyo en política monetaria y fiscal
pero creo que no es apropiado que
tratemos de decir al congreso
exactamente lo que debe hacer o en qué
momento o en qué magnitud
vamos a europa y es que se redujo ahí
sus pronósticos de crecimiento para el
próximo año daniela si la comisión
europea la comisión económica de la
unión europea dijo que tendrán que
esperar hasta 2023 para que el pib de la
zona euro vuelva a los niveles
anteriores al surgimiento del virus en
este sentido cree que las restricciones
se van a mantener en cierto grado hasta
2022 pero que el próximo año serán más
suaves aunque no tan suaves como para
que se cumpla la anterior estimación de
crecimiento que era del 61 por ciento
porque en general se prevé que el pib de
la unión europea se contraiga alrededor
de entre un 7 4% y un 7 8% para este año
en la zona euro
force one version para el 2021 lo
previsto será del 41 al 42 en la zona
euro y para el 2022 y la del 3% durante
tu daniela hablemos de este millonario
escándalo financiero en el vaticano el
papa francisco ya está moviendo pues
fichas en el vaticano no en medio de
este escándalo hablan todo comenzó hace
más de un año cuando se supo de un
acuerdo de compra de una propiedad de
lujo en londres con dinero del vaticano
eso les costó el puesto a casi una
decena de empleados y creó un agujero en
las finanzas de al menos 400 millones de
euros el papá despidió en septiembre al
cardenal ángelo beccio quien era el
número dos de la secretaria de estado
por supuesta malversación de fondos y
nepotismo y hoy el máximo representante
de la iglesia católica despojó a la
entidad de la gestión de sus propios
fondos y los movió a otra dependencia
incluso
me planteo que se debe cerrar la
decisión no es de poca monta de lan
porque porque la secretaria de estado es
el departamento más importante del
vaticano supervisar la diplomacia y los
asuntos generales de la santa sede y ha
sido el que ha manejado los recursos
históricamente entre ellos un fondo
anual para las organizaciones benéficas
del papá danía nos has estado
identificando muy interesante mente las
empresas que les ha ido mejor en tiempos
de pandemia y no sólo es silicon valley
quienes se han beneficiado hay otras
empresas del mundo que están sacando el
mejor provecho de esta crisis pero ya
sabemos de los beneficios
extraordinarios de silicon valley pero
esto no pasa sólo en eeuu
mire a lan por ejemplo la japonesa
nintendo sus ganancias se triplicaron
entre abril y septiembre hasta 2.000
millones de dólares adivine por qué todo
el mundo en casa jugando y en este
periodo vendió casi 5 millones de
unidades del super del juego super mario
3d stars vamos también con en argentina
mercadolibre se consolida como la
empresa más valiosa de américa latina
pasó de perder 118 millones a ganar
50 millones de dólares entre enero y
septiembre y la gigante china de
comercio alibaba no se queda atrás sus
ventas superaron los 46 mil millones de
dólares en el primer semestre fiscal soy
cliente de los 13 daniela java de bonos
con los indicadores del día usted
continúa con su buena racha electoral
por tercer día sus principales índices
tuvieron ganancias de más del 2% las
bolsas europeas se contagiaron de ese
optimismo madrid fráncfort parís todas
arriba en américa latina las bolsas
están en sintonía también argentina
méxico y brasil suben a la parte nueva
york zorra músculos y predio electoral
por supuesto 14.000 millones de dólares
que costó la campaña de eeuu esta cifra
es casi el doble que hace cuatro años
según la afp muy bien daniela muchas
gracias por el recorrido y gracias a
ustedes por su compañía no se despegue
france24
[Música]